hey paul why don't you chime in i mean
you joined in you haven't really had an
opportunity to talk about uh female
delusion in 2021 i know you coach a lot
of women too so what's your experience
been with that
yeah so experience has been that
it's it's this instagram lie
you know what i mean they're on social
media they're presenting a sliver
of who they are and they're getting a
ton of social proof
for that little sliver that they're
presenting you know photo filters
clever angles you know all that stuff
and then they get these guys on there
lonely beta guys who aren't getting laid
who are liking and harding and dropping
in their dms
and it's like they get this extremely
inflated view
of themselves and their opportunities
out there
and what ends up happening at some point
they get a big fat reality check
after maybe getting banged out by a few
alphas but having those guys not stay
with them
right or having to deal with you know
the sexual marketplace and so many beta
ass men out there
they get this reality check and at some
point and they realize
not all of them all right we're talking
the kinds of women that that call me for
coaching
it's like they get a big hit of reality
that hey you know this is
empty this is lonely this isn't really
what
i want you know what i mean i want if i
want to have
you know a good partner in a
relationship and
you know have all the good things in
life right
maybe that blue pill fantasy but that's
that they want that
the way to go about that and get that
isn't
what with what they're doing which is
riding the carousel
you know and just kind of getting as
much male attention as possible
and so that's pretty much the one the
women that figure this out
they start looking for a different way
but what percentage is that though right
a really small percentage so
i would say as far as any kind of
solutions to these problems
here's the thing vaginas
are going to respond to the same things
all right
that they responded to 50 years ago 100
years ago
a hundred thousand years ago so if you
can be
that alpha dude all right and you know
how to be the vagina whisperer
right in other words use game and you
cut right
into that hindbrain communicate
attraction
in it to that high which is what
seduction is
what game is what a lot of guys game
that's what we're trying to
do right you cut right through all the
[ __ ]
they will turn into your a little will
turn into
a feminine person for you because they
fall right to their instincts which
their instincts
is and so they're walking around without
a male leader to say say like that that
is what it is else
and they're being more like men and then
they drop in
and they finally attraction and desire
for an alpha guy who keeps friend what
ends up happening they end up acting
like a little girl
i've had strong you know independent
type women women
type that when they're with me they're
feminine
they're little girls because that's
their instinct and they fall right into
that if you know how to
have that presence now some women are
going to be so lost
and if they start to have those feelings
of actually being a woman
okay they'll shut it down you know
they'll act like a [ __ ] they'll
they'll stop calling you whatever you
don't mean they'll they'll get
die away from it there are some of those
but for the most part if you maintain
frame
and you can show every person
watching this really can be that guy
there's some that guy is somewhere in
them you don't have to look like
you know super jacked alpha guy or
anything it's
part of our instincts to be that guy so
you tap into that instinct your alpha
instinct
you cut right through all the [ __ ]
and so that's that's my advice and my
observation you know women around me
don't act like
you know what i mean act like they're
strong independent cells when they're
not around me
you know what i mean so every once in a
while you gotta call them a [ __ ]
and show them the front door if you have
to right yeah exactly
you